you know the notation so y equals
absolute value about to see those
vertical bars that tells us the absolute
value and what does the absolute value
do it takes whatever this quantity is
inside of those absolute value bars and
after you simplify it you always turn it
into a positive number so it's always a
positive value so let's go ahead and
plot the parent function this basic
function here by picking some negative
values and some positive values okay so
when I put negative 3 in the absolute
value that's really telling us you know
like what's that distance from zero is
it you know how far is it from the you
know from zero well if you were to go on
the number line you can see here's
negative three it's actually three units
from 0 granted it's three to the left
but that distance is always positive so
this is going to be three the absolute
value of negative two again we make that
positive negative one it becomes
positive one 0 the absolute value of
zero is zero
now here are sometimes students make a
little bit of a mistake number the
absolute value always makes it positive
it doesn't make it the opposite I just
make some positive so 1 is gonna be 1 2
is gonna be 2 and 3 is going to be 3 all
we have to do now is plot these
coordinates from the origin so we've got
left 3 up 3 right left 2 up 2 left 1 up
1 0 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 and what you'll notice
with me when you graph these absolute
value graphs it has that real sharp V
shape that real sharp corner to it so
that's our basic graph but now let's see
we want to do more challenging one say
for example ones that are in this form
here y equals a absolute value of x
minus h plus K so how does this work
well the H okay is what shifts the graph
left and right okay so this number this
group with the X it's easy to remember
it's just that in the x axis Direction
left and right but this one has the
opposite effect on the graph so that
means if it's X minus 2 it would
actually go positive 2 so to the right
if it was X plus 2 it would actually go
negative 2 so to the left too but this K
value actually has the same effect on
the graph meaning if it's positive
you're going to shift it up and if it's
negative gonna shift it down okay then
what the a value does is it stretches
the graph or compresses the graph okay
and if it's negative what it'll do it
will reflect the graph over the
taxes if a is greater than one it's a
vertical stretch if it's between zero
and one like a half at the vertical
shrink let's take a look at some
examples so you can see how this works
so say for example this one here y
equals negative two absolute value of X
minus one plus four okay what I like to
do is I like to do the translation or
the shift first so what is this minus
one right here due to the graph okay
well if you said right one you're right
and then plus four what does that do up
for remember this one has the opposite
effect this one has the same effect as
the sign so minus one we're going to go
right one up four and there's going to
be our vertex our vertex is this point
here with a graph badness right now the
negative two we talked about how the
negative is going to reflect it over the
x axis that means this grass going to be
opening down like this and because this
a value is greater than one okay the
absolute value of that is greater than
one it's gonna be a vertical stretch
okay so what that means is this graph is
going to actually be opening down but
it's gonna be stretched which means it's
going to be narrower that's going down
faster but an easy way to graph these
absolute value graphs is to think of
this a value like the slope so negative
two we can think of that as a negative
two over one so from this point we're
going to go down to right one but notice
it's symmetric meaning it's the same
about both sides of that acts as a
symmetry that vertex so if we go down to
right one we can also go down to left
one and we can repeat that process down
to right one and same thing over here we
go down to left one and see we're
getting this nice V